c'est alain chamfort
alors si vous voulez écouter mes
chansons vous cliquez là si vous voulez
vous abonner à une chanson vous cliquez
là
gianni souris tout
la radio tous avoir décliné les yeux
j'en suis rendu
john
jean
ciao
toi qui brillent comme l'astre solaire
je ne suis qu'un vieil ours polaires
jamais croire
ciao
les gens
alou
jean
tha
même jeu
jay
je croyais en sécurité à l'abri dans
l'obscurité mais toi tu viennes
tourmenté
je sais la tyrannie du bonheur quand
délectable dictateur tu veux m'imposer
en douceur
sol
zhan
toi et anti char mais sans dire je ne
suis qu'un loup solitaire
je pensais rester saine
sur l'histoire
je ne
touati
ducasse agents nevers
attends je m'étais
pour découvrir ou redécouvrir mes
chansons vous pouvez vous abonner à la
chaîne et la chanson